Speaker 1: OK, so we've talked a lot today about
the sort of general political circumstances of the
U.S., the creeping authoritarianism and some
of the other cultural and political concerns,
let's now talk a little bit more about elections
and the sort of picture that's forming about not
only twenty twenty two, but also 2024, because
there really appears to be a solidifying movement
behind Donald Trump for twenty, twenty four.
There appears to be energy behind this.
And we've already gone over the report of Trump
telling people he'll be reinstated by August.
I've already told you that Trump is restarting
the MAGGA rallies as soon as later this month.
And there is now a new report out from
The Washington Post that Donald Trump
is increasingly obsessed with these bogus sort of
kuhnen ballot audits that are happening in Arizona
and potentially in other places. Check out these
excerpts from The Washington Post, which writes,
quote, Advisers say he voraciously watches any
television coverage he can find of the Arizona
recount and reads everything he can get his hands
on about the audits, according to one person who
speaks to Trump frequently. Listen, Trump doesn't
read. If Trump is reading anything, you know, he's
obsessed with it. To get Trump to read something
really means it's unusual. The quote goes on
and he has made supporting his claims of a stolen
election or at least remaining silent about them,
a litmus test of sorts as he decides whom
to endorse for state and federal contests
in twenty twenty two and twenty twenty four.
This goes directly to what we talked about
earlier. One of the big three reasons that so many
Republicans currently in power voted against the
January six Trump riot commission is they want
to stay on Donald Trump's good side. And this
report from The Washington Post tells us Trump
is paying attention in terms of who he supports
in twenty two and or twenty for The Washington
Post continues, quote, Everyone is talking about
Arizona, he said to an adviser who tried to
broach twenty twenty two endorsements. He
brings up the topic at various events, even at
nonprofit galas, at his private Mar a Lago Club,
where he has made impromptu appearances this
spring. They said anyone who tell anyone who tells
him that he lost, one adviser said, is pissing
into the wind when advisers write speeches for
him that do not refer to attempts to relitigate
the twenty twenty election Trump ad libs riffing
on states in granular detail. Now, in addition to
this, the Associated Press is now reporting that
multiple people who have spoken with Donald
Trump and his team in recent weeks say they
sense a shift, with Trump increasingly acting and
talking as though he does plan to mount another
White House bid. Here is Trump on the Dan Bongino
show just a few days ago, Trump seeming to hint at
running in twenty twenty four. Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: I'd be remiss. The audience is
dying here, and I know you've been asked a
thousand times, forgive me, but I have to ask,
where are we with 2020 for you? We need you.
We need a big time. You thinking about it? Are
you leaning one way? We'd love to hear it.
Speaker 4: Well, I'll tell you what. We are
going to make you very happy and we're going to do
what's right. And we've done a great job for the
country, rebuilt our military and had the greatest
economy ever twice. You know, we've rebuilt it and
the world collapsed with the whole world collapse
with it. And then we built it again with the stock
market was higher than it was even the first time.
Speaker 1: OK, so every indication right now
is that this twenty, twenty four nomination
is Trump's for the taking if he wants it.
The Republican Party has shown no interest in
blocking Trump in any real way, assure Mitt
Romney would block him if he could. But Mitt
Romney is not the Republican Party right now,
even though, remember, Trump led to Republicans
losing the House in twenty eighteen, losing the
Senate in 2020 and losing the White House in
twenty twenty, they should be saying this guy
is toxic for us, but he's in control right now.
There is every indication that most Republicans
are going to fall in line and go with Trump
because they themselves want Trump's endorsement
and they need Trump's recommendation. And that's
going to be a factor in twenty, twenty two. Now,
what could at this point sideline Trump for twenty
twenty for one thing would be obviously if he just
doesn't want it, then he's out. But I'm saying
if Trump wants twenty twenty four, what could
sideline him. One thing would be that the people
he supports in twenty twenty two lose most of
them. All of them. A bunch of them. That will
reduce Donald Trump's power because that would
mean that the Trump led GOP will then have
lost the House in twenty eighteen, the Senate
in twenty twenty, the White House in twenty twenty
and at least not taken control of the House and or
Senate in twenty twenty two. That would be bad for
Trump's chances in twenty twenty four. So this is
why twenty two matters so much if the Trump wing
gets. Crushed next year, it has a potentially big
impact on twenty twenty for whoever wins, twenty
twenty four will be president until January of
twenty twenty nine. So understand the effect that
twenty twenty two has. But they are building this
entire infrastructure with the upcoming rallies
and everything else. And unless something gets
in the way, even if it's Republicans themselves
getting in the way, Trump is sailing towards the
nomination in twenty twenty four if he wants it
now. OK, the other issue of course would be a
health problem for Trump. I get a ton of emails
about this that could happen with anybody I
know. People maybe focus on Trump more because he
appears so unhealthy in the obesity and everything
else. But, you know, the truth is that anybody
when you're talking about a race that's three,
four years out that could affect anybody. And
this is why, as we mentioned earlier, historians
are so worried about the continued march towards
authoritarianism based on the polling right now,
based on Trump's continued support from within
the GOP electorate. Right now, it really appears
that No. One, they've learned nothing from the
last five years. And number two, they seem to be
totally unfazed by the creeping authoritarianism
of that trump and wing of the Republican Party.
I'm increasingly convinced that if the
party was planning to shift away from Trump,
they would have already done it. And I know people
will say, well, you got three years if they don't
shift away for the start of 2022 and Trump is left
in the position of dictating who's on the good
list and the bad list for Republicans, the ship
will have sailed and it will be Trump in control